boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host on sakyan we
are on site in Manhattan in New York
City New York and we are going to be
talking about all things
entrepreneurship all things ambition
today we're going to be talking about
Kevin siskar and all of his work I'm
really excited to be featuring you on
the show thank you for having me well
glad to be back I'm excited to be on for
a second time it's amazing yes and we
did a Skype the first time and now we're
in New York so we're actually able to do
it in person super pumped right here on
the heart of Fifth Ave Midtown I love it
right that's right right near Central
Park
um it's exciting stuff that you're
working on Kevin is an investor with a
portfolio of over 100 early stage tech
companies he's also for six and a half
years been working with the founder
Institute in New York he's now the
managing director of the founder
Institute he's a host of ambition
today's podcast and he's a venture
partner with outbound Ventures and a
co-founder of the New York City
Innovation Collective so there's a lot
of entrepreneurs ship conversation we're
going to be having there's a lot of like
really aspiring Founders and just people
that are really motivational that we're
going to be talking about and pumped to
do that
and it was really great last time I was
in New York I came in and helped Mentor
for fi here I did thank you for for
taking the time to do that I appreciate
it you jumped in and mentored one of the
sessions for the for the New York
Founders it was awesome and they were
you at a diverse group I'm I really like
the there's a lot you guys are in a lot
of cities yeah like two 200 cities 200
cities thousands of entrepreneurs have
graduated and their their companies are
flourishing and so okay let's let's talk
I really like to talk about a big
history synthesis of reality to start
off each show all right let's do it so
okay so we find ourselves as these Human
animals and now we are uh stewards of
Earth
okay and we are now hockey sticking up
in population yeah or 7.7 billion of us
uh we haven't really grown up too much
uh from like kindergarten but we're
still doing exponential technology look
at Dan Brown Inferno situation real soon
did you read that book yeah okay yeah
yeah what do you what do you think is
the current state of humanity
whoa so
um I think it's an interesting time
um I think that populations going insane
we're at we're we have an information
problem right now clearly with what is
truth you know and we went through this
before when newspapers became big and
the printing press blew up
um but you know recent stats in 2010 uh
two and a half billion people were
online
as of Friday before Christmas half of
the world population is now online 3.75
billion people yeah so we've doubled the
size of the internet in the last six or
seven years mostly because people that
didn't have access to broadband or dial
up they had flip phones those flip
phones when they bought their next phone
with smartphones and that had internet
access right and so all these people are
coming online across the world and it's
30 dollar smartphones they're really
cheap ones yeah exactly but now they
have access to Internet is that the
knowledge base the collective learning
base of civilization yeah yeah and so
you're you know in New York in New York
in the U.S you know we're across the
street from Trump Tower right now we
have our own issues with with what that
means for democracy and the government's
been shut down for 30 days it's having
serious issues it's causing real
problems for the world uh and then other
parts of the world like Sri Lanka you
have issues where I don't know if you
saw last year the Facebook post where
people on Facebook were were you know
slandering a restaurant in racist ways
and then people actually showed up at
the front door and started smashing
windows and so all around the world were
having very similar issues and problems
with information and how it's handled
and I think that is probably the biggest
well climate change
is the biggest thing facing the world
than from an information perspective
that's probably the biggest thing facing
society as a whole and a problem we need
to solve I would think ding so that
that's that's a really good point that
where the the way that we're dealing
with uh the data flows that that we have
are kind of like at the kindergarten
level we haven't really figured out how
to handle it in the most efficient way
possible
um and I touched on climate change there
it's like we're all sitting here
wondering why no one is doing anything
about it but it really is sort of the
same problem no one knows what's true no
one really knows how to act on it what
you know the next steps are
um it feels like there's really no
problem true thing about it is that
humans are affecting the climate by
burning fossil fuels that seems to be
the most true thing the oceans are
acidifying the parts Familiar of CO2 are
increasing so we can actually tell some
things the power part of the ice sheets
are melting we can we can see some
things yeah
um but and and we can see really bad air
quality in in what some of the major
city these in India and China even
California California I was out there in
November you guys had the wildfires we
did yeah your air quality was worse than
Beijing it was it was the worst I was
there it smelled horrible it smelled
like plastic
um and you know those fires are a result
of global warming so it's affecting
everywhere
um yeah sure so so my my follow-up and
with the data thing we have big huge
data silos we don't have
decentralization of data flows yet
enabling us to best understand all of
your Biometrics all of your data make it
relatable to you have you have ownership
and get paid for it maybe like a
universal basic income there's so many
cool ways to explore that so I'm curious
what do you think then are some of the
best ways to collaborate geopolitically
on data and climate
so sharing data with companies or with
the government
just how do we how do we best move
forward on climate and data
geopolitically how do you think we
should do that oh boy I know solve our
pressing challenges yeah let me go
um I mean I think there's political
challenges that have to be solved there
right you have uh you know right now in
Washington I was there over the weekend
you have people you know putting their
personal agendas and re-election uh
priorities in front of the will of the
people and the overall health of
humanity right and so when you have
people doing that it's corruption right
uh that does the definition of
corruption and it becomes really hard to
solve these problems the U.S pulled out
of the Paris Accord all these you know
it's really messed up so how do you
solve it I I wish if I had the answer uh
I would be tweeting it constantly
um I don't know that I have the answer I
think
um one of the things you know the reason
that I work in startups is I don't have
all the answers and I know that
but I can work with amazing people that
do have the answers I can support them
yes and so by working with great
Founders that are maybe working in the
political space or building software or
things that can fix these problems
that's how I look to have an impact on
the world
I feel like a major part of what you
just said there is that we have to kind
of grow up away from our own egocentric
greedy corrupt habits and move towards a
Unity of all beings on this single Tribe
Called Earth yeah and when we can
transition to that we can move away from
some of the greed and some of the
corruption we can raise the Baseline of
living for everyone and prosper more
collectively I think that was a huge
point and then the next point we can
just transition directly into how
entrepreneurs are saving the world
because in many ways they totally are
so you support entrepreneurs that have
these big ideas on how to save the world
and this this has been over 100 plus
Investments for you this has also been a
bunch of entrepreneurs that have been
launched from the New York City chapter
a Founder Institute and founder
Institute is this super ideal process of
taking your idea Product Company and
really launching it off at the end of
how long's the period it's about three
and a half months three so three and a
half month period and then by you're
getting the you're getting some of the
world's best mentors you're getting some
of the world's best processes of how to
become an entrepreneur and so tell us
about how you're supporting the
entrepreneurs and these really good
ideas yeah sure so at the basic level we
run founder Institute it's a three and a
half month startup accelerator we're
actually kicking off the new cohort here
in New York tonight oh yeah uh you know
we've mentors uh like David Rose to
start a New York Angels We Have the
founder of Skip Hop coming uh just sold
for 140 million he's coming tomorrow
night so you get access to these really
amazing entrepreneurs in New York that
can come in once a week in the evening
for dinner share their lessons
um you know they'll pitch on their story
on whatever that week's topic is those
are invaluable yeah 100 yeah access to
the network especially in a city like
New York is amazing
um and so you'll hear them present each
other's stories you'll pitch them get
feedback directly on your business ask
questions then we sort of all go out and
have a few drinks together that period
is so funny when because I remember
being on the other side of the table
when I was pitching and I would the
number one thing I think for me was
always being open to the feedback no
matter how harsh it was yeah that was
the most important thing because people
aren't gonna aren't gonna soft uh put
icing on everything right um they're
gonna they're gonna they're gonna tell
you an aggressive way sometimes how to
change your your plan and so you got to
be really open to all different types of
feedback and then actually oh in it and
then incorporating it and iterating on
your project and so that was really
crucial and then it was really strange
sitting on the other side of the table
where I was giving feedback because I
was always trying to be you know be kind
but also be serious about the changes
they need to make
um sometimes if you're too kind the
point just gets missed exactly that's
right yeah yeah yeah
um but sometimes when you're super
aggressive they'll close off exactly so
so these sort of it's like a closed
closed loop feedback back system of
mentors to entrepreneurs and that seems
to be one of the most crucial parts of
founder Institute yeah I mean it's great
you know and and the best part is when
you know sometimes the mentors take a
personal invested interest in these
companies Beyond just the founder
student sessions right so a lot of times
they sign on to be direct advisors for
these companies formally stay with them
you know really work with them so that's
that's great too yeah and then besides
the closed loop feedback systems with
mentors which I still think is just
mind-blowing because that's what so many
young entrepreneurs are missing is just
their ability to be able to go and talk
to like three or five other somewhat
successful entrepreneurs and just hear
from them about what they can do better
because if that was just more readily
available I think we would more easily
have more entrepreneurs
um so okay besides that tell us about
the other epicness that happens in this
three and a half yeah sure so you're put
in a working group simulate supported
directors uh going to your point earlier
it's about seven things about human
that's limiting everything right
um we're all as humans really bad at
holding ourselves even to our own goals
right and so
the the working group simulated support
of directors you meet with them twice a
week and really their job is to hold you
true to your own goals and keep you
accountable which is really hard as a
Founder especially
um you know when you're maybe for the
first time in your life breaking out
from a structured corporate you have a
boss you know employee relationship uh
to finally having to like set an agenda
for yourself and keep yourself
accountable to it uh you know we may be
working from home and there's
distractions in your home and it's
really hard to build that regiment and
that routine and so we help we help you
sort of start a built to build those
habits and Foster that you also have
about 30 hours of curriculum assignments
each week that and those are company
building things right so those are
things like for the legal assignment
um you know can I can you incorporate a
C Corp in Delaware right and so all
these things are very foundational and
by the time you leave the program you
actually have done the work for your
company not just learned how to
that's that's right so you're actually
helping them understand what are some
good steps and then they go and execute
on these steps so they can gain the
actual experience yes from the process
and then really put that into
their literally put it into through
epigenetic processing into themselves
and then add that to other people's
lives by passing it along to other
people that way more and more people
know how to incorporate businesses they
know how to actually put together
business plans and go and pitch and
raise money and sell a product to Market
learn how to Market it learn how to
manufacture things one of the
interesting things at that point is like
we're not the company Institute we're
the founder Institute right and so uh
more often than not you see these people
have these personal growth stories and
even if they don't hit it out of the
park on their first company you they
come they do a second company and you
know really you can just see that
they've grown they've learned they can
just execute so much better in the
months going forward
yeah that's what I'm saying that that
slow that or that that even after just
three and a half months just it's a it's
a day it's a day today you you gotta you
gotta hustle you gotta Hustle but then
at the end it breatheses it seems like
it breathes by and then you're so much
more ready to tackle what you need to do
moving forward and we've and we've added
postgraduate programs now so you know we
have equity in these companies we want
to see this will succeed they're in the
family
um so we help with fundraising product
traction and we help the founders for
the life of the company both here in New
York uh and then also out of our
headquarters in in California yeah yeah
that's so crucial is there's a continued
process even after they fly out of the
nest you're still helping them yeah with
some currents of wind to help them fly
um
now what percentage of the
of the companies that you see are in
like software Hardware
Etc yeah so we're industry agnostic we
will build whatever the founders want to
build so I have food companies drone
companies I just had my first biotech
company that's doing yeah you'll
probably like this they're doing uh they
partnered with NASA because NASA has a
patent commercialization program so they
had a carbon nanotube mesh capsule and
then they uh one of the co-founders is
from Wheel Cornell and he engineered his
own cells that basically will produce
the enzymes to eliminate blood
transfusions for fabric diseases and so
they're putting those cells in the NASA
capsules and so basically someone with a
fabric disease could just get this
injection and have that changed every
six months versus going to the hospital
every two weeks to take four hours of
blood transfusions damn so they're
called CAP cell biologics
um you know and then we also have
um you know school and education and Ed
Tech and you know Amazon
automation scripts there's you know
there's we're interesting nastics so
we'll really help a Founder build what
is lies of the expertise at the
crossroads of their own personal
expertise and network yeah and this is
what really helps for not only are you
industry agnostic which is huge because
then you can take on whoever you want
but it's also interesting to see and
hear all these different Industries like
you just listed which are which are not
only does that build up a new sort of
mentor's ship
array that you guys get to have it
builds up in those mentors it's really
important for them to also have a broad
lens on the world as well so they can
help Mentor all the different companies
that are coming in it's really
interesting because there's there's a
debate in Venture Capital right now I
guess not a debate but there's uh
competing strategies of do you build a
niche accelerator right like do we build
the the retail accelerator and we only
have retail mentors we only have retail
companies because we can then leverage
more specifically for the founders or do
you build a general success rate which
is kind of the way the path itself found
institute's built that's how techstars
why commentator is all built versus like
Indie bio which is specifically biotech
right yeah and so one of the things
we've done is is we've really pushed for
scale we're in 200 cities but what
that's done is we have 10 000 mentors in
our system around the world and so we
can tag those mentors by by expertise
and by Geo and then we can build
software to automate those niches within
our Global Network right so we're doing
things a little bit differently
um but we're really confident in the
long game and what it comes to yeah the
the tagging of the mentors is super
important and then the
um just being able to pair mentors up
with uh young aspiring entrepreneurs is
super important yeah the the closer
Loops that you create with automation
software will be very interesting in the
future that you built out 10 000 Mentor
Network that's so interesting and so
crucial across the world there seems to
be I would say a lack of
Entrepreneurship in high schools and
even younger
because kids don't even really realize
that they can pursue ideas their
imaginations that they can actually go
and execute them and start even
businesses as simple as making websites
at Young ages and then Distributing
products or ideas through those websites
how old were you when you built your
first website I believe it was
Distributing Collegiate clothing so it
was I think around uh 1819 really I
think so I built my first website in the
fifth grade see that's badass but it was
like you know back then it was uh it was
geocities right which I think you would
basically just you know template or
build stuff out I I didn't code right
um but I think to your point you know my
podcast ambition today I interview a lot
of entrepreneurs about their Journey
right and we always start with the
childhood because I'm always trying to
find the little steps that that led to
their success right yeah
um and one of the things I found about
links in the bio for ambition today go
and go and check it out we'll be talking
everywhere podcast
yeah but but seriously so one of the
things I found is is the most successful
entrepreneurs most of them today had
some sort of entrepreneurial influence
in their childhood totally and they may
not have even realized it but they had
an uncle or or or a you know a father or
a mother or someone that encouraged
these habits in them
um and they didn't really realize it and
then later in life you know things just
sort of match up in college when you're
trying to figure out and they realize
that oh wow I fit in with that group of
people and they're entrepreneurs and
this is what they do and so yeah
um you know I would say it's really
important and we probably don't do
enough of it in in high school yeah um
to to spark that curiosity is even
making this geocities website or even
making you going into your Java coding
class this is not enough this is this is
the Bare Bones of what is needed there's
like a whole new way of teaching
entrepreneurship to young people that is
yet to be really discovered and um and
and implemented in scalable ways and
with these close-up Mentor feedback
systems and all this type of stuff that
I think is going to the imagination of
kids is so vivid and interesting and so
we gotta really enable that that better
um you know you started talking about
these these influences that come in I
think another one of the crucial
influences is uh anti-conformist
thinking yeah
when I looked out at the world I was
like this is come on why is everyone and
their mother doing nine to five work I'm
like there's got to be something else
about life where we can get out of the
cubicles and the rat race yeah I was
like I'm gonna do something that I love
every single day and I don't give a
if I'm poor as I would rather be
poor as and doing what I love than
working for someone else hating my job
yeah for sure yeah and so that's I think
that's a big Mantra of our of Our
Generation though too right
um yeah there was a good BuzzFeed
article a few weeks ago about
um burnout and why Millennials think the
way they do and why you know going to
the post office and sending a letter is
just so daunting but like and we won't
crave everything in like a one-click app
button right
um really good article it's called how
the homologous became the burnout
generation it's a long read but it's a
really interesting real one yeah
um
but yeah I mean it's it's an interesting
Trend
um we'll see what happens with that you
know uh the Baby Boomers think that
we're all entitled we think the Baby
Boomers got you know everything that
they ever needed at upon graduation of
High School uh there was a really good
SNL skit this weekend about called uh
Millennial Millionaires and it was a
game show where uh you could win
everything that the Baby Boomers got
upon graduating high school and
Millennials are spending 20 years to get
right like paying off their student
loans and the ability to have enough
savings to buy a house and
um we're also moving into these
metropolises which is making it so that
we don't really care so much about a
house we don't really care so much about
a car we just care about being close to
the network effect yeah yeah I mean our
parents generation at least in the
United States depending on who you're
watching this everyone left the cities
for the suburbs for the suburbs 3 000
square foot houses I'm from Buffalo the
city was the wealthy a city at the turn
of the century because the Erie Canal
connected New York to the to the great
lakes and then you know the population
went in half and we're now seeing a
Resurgence over the last 10 years in
places like Buffalo Detroit and other
cities around the country but a lot of
people are moving back downtown and I
think that's partially what's driving
that yeah it even goes as far as to see
the McDonald's corporate headquarters
went all the way out to the suburbs of
Chicago and then they recently were like
uh-uh we're not getting any of the
millennial and gen Z Talent anymore so
they went and built a brand new
Headquarters downtown Chicago in the
West Loop and so that's the type of
behavior that we're seeing from these
major companies to stay relevant what
would you say are let's try with three
key principles of an entrepreneur
mindset okay
I would say
incredibly curious about really just
anything and everything and constantly
wanting to
figure out how everything works
um right and and digging in on those
following that Curiosity
um
you have to maintain some focus and and
when you're building a company versus
just experimenting you have to make sure
that Curiosity keeps you on track but I
think that's a that's a Hallmark
being really Scrappy and digging in
right and so not sitting around and
waiting for something to happen to
enable the next thing but really just
doubling down saying you know
just making it work like I don't care if
the front you have a pretty website and
on the back end there's no code and it's
a pencil and paper and you running
around you know with your AI is
connecting and matching people like just
get it done just figure out that there's
a problem and that people are willing to
pay for it to be solved right and then
from there you can start to build
software to automate things right but
but the people that sit around and for a
technical co-founder or oh I just need
money or just forget all that you just
need to get going so you know curiosity
be Scrappy as hell you know I would say
they Network
um you can't build a company on your own
like full you just can't right and so
the people that have good networks they
they make meaningful relationships at
the end of the day you in order to be an
entrepreneur you have to have meaningful
relationships you cannot just burn
people and walk all over them and so
building out that Network taking the
time to do that is is instrumental in
growing the having a shot of starting a
company and growing it those are so good
I love it
um curiosity so crucial understanding
how everything in the world works really
trying to dig deep into getting how
things work and then it's being Scrappy
yeah really focused and Scrappy being
totally cool with living a low SES in
order to be able to succeed the last
one's Network so really understanding
that your Network's your net worth you
got to go and and parse the events that
you go to and find the top five people
at those events that have the highest
Cloud that are building the future and
go and introduce yourselves to them
provide them with value ask them how you
can help them ask them about their lives
and what they learned in their lessons
yeah and then that will tie you closer
into the loop of people that are
actually building and the other big
Advantage there is like it's 2019 right
so I have probably made more meaningful
relationships on Twitter
just you know like everything you just
said but digitally right and then I meet
those people in the real world we become
friends like you know so uh there's ways
to do this even if you're not in a New
York or an SF totally um to connect and
plug in totally
and that means when you do find that
person on the internet do not be scared
to go and dig search their name with
follow their email name email and try
and find or DM them on Twitter Etc or
Instagram wherever you're at but reach
out to them and provide them with that
value reach out that's something that so
many of us hesitate yeah just go try to
grab a coffee and uh you know
at the worst case you have some bad
conversation you've got the best case
good questions yeah that's the thing is
gotta ask them good questions because
then there's never a bad conversation so
come prepared with your five or ten
questions that you want to ask them
about their life and what they built
well I'm going to go back to curiosity
too because I feel like really curious
people have gotten good at asking the
right questions that's right and people
that aren't used to digging in uh ask
the wrong question a too general or two
off to the right or they lead the answer
right and so you have to sort of become
a scientist with those curiosity and
yeah yeah exactly I'm trying to myself
find out like you said we're testing
hypothesis every time that I ask a
question I I'm trying to not be too
leading I'm trying to yeah yeah all this
all this important stuff be emotionally
intelligent and present with the EQ
um okay a couple
um other thoughts so with ambition today
how many episodes have you done over the
last couple years we just hit episode 50
50. yes I know you're you're way ahead
of me on this but you do I do them every
like two weeks this is our only thing
yeah so just in episode 50 uh so it's
been two years then it's been almost
three years I started August 2015. uh I
took a break off before my wedding for a
few months and then we really fired it
back up in the last year so I love it um
yeah basically interviewing uh
successful entrepreneurs that have built
grown and sold the companies and and
then going through their life story
right and trying to pick apart like a
scientist the parts that you know are
replicatable for anyone else listening
um yeah and a lot of what you mentioned
earlier with the Curiosity scrappiness
and network actually is part of these
stories of entrepreneurs that you get to
yeah I would say like there's themes
right and so if you listen to you know
two three four five episodes you'll
start to see these themes arise and and
then you know the goal is ideally you
could I think everyone wants to see
themselves in the hero's journey right
and so uh people start to think about
how they can better those parts of their
life as well to be more effective for
themselves yeah yep that's really
crucial again you're learning from the
best and you're implementing those
skills into your life that's something
that we gotta hustle you we have the
conscious Choice every single day is am
I going to watch Jeff Bezos or Elon Musk
give a talk or am I going to watch a cat
video I have the conscious Choice every
day to pick or am I gonna turn off the
garyvee videos and actually do something
and actually get hustle yeah yeah
because we can get too trapped into the
cycle of only watching and not executing
100 yeah I'm guilty of that myself I
mean that's the other trap for the
curious person is like you feel like you
always just need to keep learning and at
some point it's like man you read every
book in the library like you know
exactly what you're doing you just need
to go do it yeah that's so that's a good
point is don't get trapped in too
curious to the extent of which you don't
actually build some people's I've
learned this Kevin and you might find
this interesting I've learned that some
people actually care about just hanging
out around the edge of knowledge of like
society's knowledge yeah and just like
dealing with different people on the
edge but not really like ex not really
being an entrepreneur necessarily but
just helping all the people along the
scientific or business edges of the
world so I find that when I say you got
to go execute you got to go execute
sometimes executing means having
conversations with those people at the
edge but then how do you you know
monetize that and sustain yourself Etc
yeah it depends on what your goals are
right and so if you you know I guess I'm
talking from the aspect of if you want
to start a company that's right
um you know but you're right there's
other people there and so I would I
would urge everybody to figure out what
their North Star like if you had a
personal mission statement like what is
that
um and and then figure out how you can
start to align things in your life to
you accomplishing that right my mission
statement I actually like formalized
this in the last year is I want to help
Founders improve the lives of 1 billion
people I love it and so I know that if I
were to do something I could have a
little bit of an impact but if I can
help a bunch of people have a an impact
I can then you know make my butterfly
effect impact on the world and so that's
right yeah there's I think personally as
well that there's that's mimetics you're
probably you're tiesing the
dissemination of ideas and businesses to
the world rather than I think genetics
which is a lot of people are stuck in
the procreation investing my time into
only my kids and only my family that has
caused this in many ways to be at the
end of this hockey stick of exponential
technology and hockey stick of
population without really growing up
from kindergarten much I think so yeah I
think but I think if you do the former
instead of the latter to your point
the long-term effects compound right
yeah so what I've seen is you know
investing in other people helping them
um all the stuff that you would normally
fight for in that other scenario comes
naturally absolutely absolutely now what
would you say are some of the takeaways
from the 100 plus companies you've
invested into
that's a good question I've actually
been wanting to do a blog post on this
and I haven't done it yet so this might
be a rough answer let's see
um
what are the biggest takeaways biggest
takeaways I would say are
um
it's really hard for people to get to to
get and stay in a growth mindset I think
a lot of people have the vision they
don't but then sometimes people get lost
on the bridge between where they are and
where they want to go right and so it's
really tricky it could be really hard
it's it's kind of like fighting and last
time I think I was on we talked about
pushing uh a boulder up a hill and we
got a little little carried away with
the boulder analogy so we won't do it
this time but
um I think you know really staying
focused really playing long term but
really thinking how you could build a
big globally scalable company
because I think a lot of people
sometimes you know can get some money
coming in and then they get lost in in
keeping that going right
um one of one of the analogies I like to
you know draw is um
a more and more simple business than
really anyone can understand right
whereas thinking like a snow plowing
business if you could drive one truck
um you have 40 hours a week you could do
X number of driveways right uh the
moment you do a second truck you can
then rinse and repeat that to a third or
fourth or fifth sixth and you could
scale right but in order to do that you
have to there's only so much time in a
day you have to spend less hours plowing
yes make less money for a little bit
build the business not just the way that
you sell your time to make money right
and so one thing my advice would be
after 100 companies
make sure that you're not still selling
your time
make sure that you're actually building
the business
so it can scale and repeat and really
grow long term yeah yeah that's a good
piece of advice Kevin that's a really
good one that's a that's a trap I've
seen some people fall into but yeah yeah
it's still we get super caught up in
doing the mundane at times we we hustle
our ass off to to do the first it's
almost like you get to first base in
baseball and then to get to second base
you gotta do something that requires you
to do the scaling strategies unless so
the same you can't do the same run in
the sense that you did to first base to
second base there's a different strategy
to get to second base if you're if you
only got to a base hit you know yeah and
I think the interesting thing is you
know the reality from a psychological
perspective and this goes to that
BuzzFeed article I mentioned the
millennial burnout one is we all like
doing what we're really good at and so
that comes naturally and easy to us and
so we just fall into like repeating that
and building the business in the same
way and so the problem is being an
entrepreneur you're constantly having to
force yourself to The Fringe and outer
parts of your comfort zone always to hit
that next thing to hit that next thing
hit the next thing so you almost have to
become
compared to anyone else in society doing
any other job you have to sort of become
this weirdo who's who's enjoying this
like place of discomfort and always
forcing yourself to grow in a little bit
and it's a it's a hard position to keep
yourself in day in and day out it
requires a lot of physical health yes I
believe uh totally it requires a lot of
mental health it requires a lot of daily
processes and routine and it's for me
it's a mindset that people can get
themselves in yeah versus you know just
a job that they do damn this is Super
Wise advice I love it I love it bro this
is so good this is so good
um there's so many things there uh you
you know you mentioned that you know
mental and physical health are so
crucial in this process that's why
meditation and exercise and eating
healthy are super important doing things
like fasting getting eight hours of
sleep all these crucial crucial pieces
to this puzzle and then also you
mentioned like just being at the brink
of what you like don't know how to do
and like constantly pushing at that
Brink it's like the most satisfying
thing is that deep Instinct of of being
at because you never want to be doing
things that are too easy and you never
want to be doing things that are so hard
that you just keep failing all the time
so you got to be right at that edge and
working at that edge this hugely
important piece of advice and I just
like I'm so obsessed with the fact that
you said this I'm just I'm just trying
to think of like
of all the entrepreneurs around the
world that are just too focused on what
they are super good at within their
company that they're not doing the
Innovation and and research around what
they could do next to help their
businesses right grow and so I'm gonna
take the snowplow analogy and I'm going
to bring it to Tech business now right
and so I had a Founder recently who
um he just he was just he was at 40
hours a week he just could not get any
more and I said you have to grow the
team and unfortunately hiring someone
talking to people writing out a process
DOC for whatever it is they're going to
do right again you have to take hours
back from what you were doing to hire
and fill that Gap and then bring them up
to speed and so for probably a month and
a half two months three months you're
doing less work than you're used to
doing the business is slowing but if you
can get it done their effects are you
get that time then back and now you've
just doubled it right and so it can be
painful to hire those first few
employees and and it you could become a
bottleneck because you it's really easy
to say I know how to do it I've done it
15 times I'll just do it real quick
versus teaching someone else to do it
that's right and you fall in that trap
and you you could do that for months to
a year or two yeah and uh reality is you
should have just got help a while ago
and so my other advice after 100 people
is make sure you get help make sure you
know just find people that you enjoy
spending time with and get them around
you and you just need to jam out and
work together and and just keep pushing
each other push each other forward
looking at myself in the mirror right
now and thinking about all the ways that
I am going to be doing this editing for
years and it's so important to find the
right people because you can do the
training and then it can be they can be
gone and that's a big time investment
that you may have lost so this is all
super important
um okay just some quickies on the way
out
um quick questions that we like to ask
our guests
what would you say is a core driving
principle of yours
core driving principle so the one of the
reasons I came up with that mission
statement right hub Founders improve the
lives of a billion people is because I
found myself doing all these things
right I run founder Institute I then
started the podcast to interview the
interview the mentors the New York City
Innovation Collective is a non-profit of
all the acceleration incubators in New
York
um and part of part of the I got to the
point where I was like well I'm doing
too much but
I I needed to ask myself does it does it
all align right what can I cut that is
not part of my life goals right and what
can I what can I keep and so the mission
statement for me is that it's my North
Star it's what keeps me going uh they
all in my opinion help Founders improve
the lives of a billion people
um either directly or indirectly and so
that's why those are sort of the core
things that that I I believe in
um
yeah yeah
and then if you could rebuild
civilization from scratch how would you
design it oh man just like Epcot I'm
just kidding but but
I am fascinated by you know Epcot was
Disney's vision for a futuristic city
um I it would be fascinating to you know
get a plot of land and try to like
rebuild a society I think that would be
an amazing project for the the back nine
of my life after uh we make some money
here and get some time on our hands to
just relax and plan it but you know it's
it would be fascinating I don't know
what the answer would be obviously you
know from an admissions perspective it's
got to be carbon neutral I think we've
seen that you know we're just now
starting to see things like how to build
cities well right I think we messed up a
lot in the 60s and the 70s we built
these military industrial complexes
right my my University campus is really
windy down the main Corridor turns out
that was intentional by Design because
they wanted to be able to easily gas all
the students if there was a riot because
everyone was you know throwing protests
in the 50s and 60s and so you know these
misaligned incentives are are you know
have created these scenarios that bad
design the Barbican in London so what
we're seeing now is you know New York
City is starting to figure things out
like in the last five years they added a
thousand miles of bike Lanes right that
have reduced the number of accidents the
parking protected you know we're
starting to see people move downstairs I
I'm confident in the next in the next 15
to 20 years of human design the question
is going to be whether or not we can fix
the the mistakes we've already made
do you think that we're in a simulation
cue the Red Hot Chili Peppers
um
I don't know and how would I ever know
right like if we're in The Matrix uh
uh does it doesn't matter do I still
play the game right like I I still want
to win the game there's no there's
nothing there's no way to unplug from
the game so
um
yeah I don't know keep leveling up yeah
keep leveling up and and and hope hope
to God or or whatever it is that uh you
know when we when we pass on there's uh
something better
we'll hack the code we'll figure it out
soon Kevin yeah how about last question
is
what do you think's the most beautiful
thing in the world ah those beautiful
thing in the world and I think you asked
me this before so I wonder if I'm going
to give a different answer then than
last time
uh I don't remember what I said last
people evolve yeah so
let's hear it let's hear it the most
beautiful thing in the world
I'm maybe because you got me in that
space But I'm gonna go with life again I
think it's just a shot at whether it's a
simulation or not it's a shot at
something at you know coming up with a
mission statement impact leaving your
impact on the world one of my favorite
things that you talk about is all the
people that lived before us right and
how many people like 100 billion 100
billion yeah 100 billion people right
and and you know someone in this
generation probably didn't build this
building but we're standing on these
floors 14 stories up and we're we're
hanging out and um and we're we're
existing and living off of Subway
systems and other other Generations
built um and even though we pay for them
you know two dollars a ride
um all this infrastructure is cumulative
and so
yeah I mean life right I mean it allows
us to do that as a society and so I
would say you know life is obviously the
most beautiful thing I love it I love it
Kevin I love it and super grateful for
you and for all the people that have
built everything that we have today and
thank you so much for coming onto the
show enjoy yeah thanks for having me
super fun looking forward to the next
one and uh here's to the next 50 years
yeah yeah we got this I hope we we got
the civilization we got this everyone
thank you so much for tuning in we
greatly appreciate it give us your
thoughts in the comments below we would
also like you to check out some of
Kevin's links and some of the work
um you can check that out in the links
below again for founder and student and
for ambition today
also go and build the future everyone
manifests your destiny into the world go
and execute we love you so much and keep
supporting keep supporting great
entrepreneurs and great organizations
and support us we can keep doing cool
things like coming on site and talking
to Epic people like Kevin much love and
we'll see you soon everyone stay curious
everyone stay curious